et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
rogers cohen bonjour bonjour et
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes l'une
des grandes plumes du new york times
pour lequel vous travaillez de pluie
trentaine d'années aujourd'hui à la tête
du bureau parisien du quotidien
américain pour lequel vous avez été
aussi dans le désordre correspondant
chef du service étranger éditorialistes
et reporter de guerre et c'est cette
casquette que je voudrais d'abord
sollicité si vous le voulez bien avant
de revenir sur l'élection présidentielle
en france vous avez découvert rogers
cohen la guerre du liban et puis au
milieu des années 90 pour le new york
times corrigez moi si je me trompe celle
des balkans et notamment le siège de
sarajevo les images que vous voyez est
que vient de diffuser dans le journal
des villes ukrainiennes donmario paul
est ce qu'elle vous le rappelle celle
que vous avez vu des trentaine d'années
bien sûr voir mario paul comme ça
assiégée bombardée
ça rappelle sarajevo qui au milieu de
l'horreur parti entouré par les forces
serbes pendant trois ans et demi en bois
et des femmes enceintes huées des
enfants enfin des images
absolument terrible et dans la guerre
évidemment on est confronté aux extrêmes
delà de la condition humaine pour un
journaliste évidemment c'est quelque
chose de très fort après la guerre j'ai
dû écrire un livre parce que je ne
pouvais pas passer de la guerre à autre
chose comme ça dans une minute terrible
de voir encore une fois la guerre en
europe on pensait comme les européens
pensaient que on avait mis fin ça quand
même pas dire c'est interroge sur la
présence de la mémoire car on dit depuis
le début on entend souvent depuis le
début de la guerre en ukraine que c'est
le début le retour de la guerre en
europe quasiment depuis un demi siècle
il a eu tant de guerre et la garde les
guerres des balkans
la mémoire collective aurait tendance à
l'oublier
il faut pas oublier qu'il a eu cent
mille morts
dans les guerres la destruction de la
yougoslavie on est encore loin de là
mais cette fois ci on a quand même une
puissance nucléaire dans cette guerre la
russie et le président poutine n'a pas
hésité à faire allusion à cet armement
nucléaire même le mettre dans une espèce
d'alert donc on entend cette inquiétude
on compare en grande entend des gens qui
parlent de la troisième guerre mondiale
j'ai entendu l'autre jour à la
boulangerie un homme qui ont parlé donc
c'est un autre monde vous avez travaillé
à hauteur d'homme pour raconter ces
conflits ceux qui la font c'est à dire
ceux qui la subissent qui sont
d'ailleurs d'autres bien souvent que
ceux qui ont décidé ces guerres en
ukraine a commis en ex-yougoslavie
la guerre donne à voir son nul humain
dans son entièreté on n'est jamais aussi
soi que dans la guerre absolument je
pense que comme journaliste j'ai
toujours été plus intéressé par comment
les histoires personnelles raconte des
histoires plus général d'une nation et
dans la guerre ben nous dans la vie
quand on se rend compte il a pas mal de
barrières dans la guerre il n'y en a pas
aucune les gens sont révélés de bons
soirs comme ça et c'est une expérience
extrêmement de fortes il faut dire que
cette guerre en ukraine ne dit pas du
tout provoquer c'est une guerre choisie
par le président poutine et ce
extraordinaire de voix qu'il a décidé
d'envoyer 150 mille russe dans ce pays
qu'il dit fraternelle c'est une guerre
fraternelle hilaire beaucoup de liens
c'est vrai entre l'ukraine et la russie
ont dépuis de ça il n'a pas hésité et on
doit se demander 2
2 commence comment est l'état mental du
président poutine en ce moment à voir
juste dit avoir lui aussi ces images
méline il les revenus d'aucuns dont le
président aux hellènes ce qu'ils font du
24 février 2000 22 jours de l'invasion
russe le 11 septembre de l'europe vous
l'avez vécu seront septembre de l'eau
côté le vrai de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
est-ce que ce parallèle en ce qu'il veut
dire du bouleversement quasi définitif
de l'ordre du monde vous paraît
acceptable cohérent je pense que c'est
un très grand d'événements néfastes
convient maintenant en europe et que
cette je ne vois pas par exemple le
président poutine un jour à la maison
blanche ou à downing street à londres on
à l'elysée non non donc on voit de
nouveau une fracture très forte en
europe sa voix des conséquences énormes
sur l'économie sur l'énergie a notamment
des augmentations de prix et surtout
est-ce que le président poutine pourrait
aller plus loin est ce qui pourrait
aller par exemple dans les pays
baltiques y faisait partie de l'union
soviétique mais qui maintenant font
partie de l'otan et le président mbaye
de matty très clair une fois l'otan
attaquée si ça a lieu c'est la guerre
est là vraiment on doit parler de la
possibilité d'une guerre globale
donc moi je trouve pas la comparaison
mal placé si ce genre d'événement mais
c'est un des événements dont tout le
monde va se souvenir et dire les choses
étaient d'une façon avant et d'une autre
après qu'est ce que l'opinion publique
américaine ou en tout cas est ce que ce
sentiment d'inquiétude existe dans
l'opinion publique américaine dans ce
moment où je pense oui inquiétudes mais
surtout colère indignation
indignation morale
très frappé par le courage quand même
des ukrainiens devant un pays justement
nucléaires un peu comme en europe enfin
on n'a pas vu je crois l'europe aussi
mobilisés par la coller à la nation
depuis très longtemps on parle de
l'union européenne mais malheureusement
cette union n'est pas toujours unie
cette fois ci pour une fois les 27 pays
vraiment sont sur une seule ligne peu
importe maintenant les différences entre
la hongrie et la france ou la pologne la
france non ça va rebattre aussi
d'ailleurs beaucoup de cartes sur la
construction européenne
le président ma crainte on parlait de
l'appui seuil de puissance je pense
qu'on est beaucoup plus proche d'une
possible sûrs puissance maintenant
qu'auparavant surtout que l'allemagne
pays généralement pacifiques depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale a choisi
maintenant le réarmement ça c'est un
changement très important
qui rend beaucoup plus possible d'une
europe puissance je vais solliciter à
présent on change de sujet coin que
rogers cohen votre casquette de chef de
bureau parisien du bureau parisien du
new york times ici à paris donc nous
sommes à 20 jours du premier tour d'une
élection présidentielle dont la campagne
a été balayée par la guerre en ukraine
en vais revenir dans un instant en
quelques mots d'abord qu'est-ce que
cette campagne nous inspire c'est pas
votre première non c'est pas ma première
c'était la fin une drôle de campagne
c'est vrai que
cette guerre a éclaté et donc d'une
manière ou d'une autre
l'élection comparé à ça a semblé moins
important et surtout on a un président
qui mène pas vraiment une campagne à nos
fins qui ce qui veut se placer au-dessus
de la mêlée et c'est comme il est le
favori et comme notion les sondages il
est il assez loin devant les autres
candidats pour le moment ça fait une
espèce de campagne dans l'ombre est-ce
que vous ne diriez pas que la guerre en
ukraine a fait tomber aussi les masques
d'une certaine façon et qu'elle a
peut-être us cet effet deux d'aller
peut-être plus à l'essentiel
oui balle à influencer la campagne de
plusieurs manières elle a permis au
président justement de se poser comme au
dessus de la mêlée comme le grand
diplomate qui essaient de résoudre ce
problème global ça posait des problèmes
embarrassant je dirais pour les
candidats de droite notamment monsieur
zemmour et madame le pen qui était très
épris de monsieur poutine est pris par
son conservatisme famille traditions la
culture chrétienne contre les musulmans
et qui avait beaucoup fait l'éloge de
monsieur poutine donc ils ont dû un peu
ils ont dû disant radicalement ajuster
leurs positions ce qui encore une fois
favori monsieur à 45 puisse coûter pour
le coup à eric zemmour qui avait plus
axé sa campagne sur la grandeur de la
france telle que marine le pen
pour les deux se tut de l'éclat on avait
dit avant avant bien sûr c'est bien
sûr au début de la campagne qu'on allait
on aller vers quelque chose d'une forme
de trump isation de la vie politique
française avec cet homme irruption
d'eric zemmour dans la campagne la
guerre en ukraine et le contexte
international a peut-être atténuer sa
mais ce que vous observez ça quand même
plus largement dans la vie politique
française ben je pense que monsieur
zemmour c'est un phénomène 30 bien si on
peut dire un homme qui vient de la
télévision qui n'a pas vraiment fait de
la politique
kiddo qui dit tous les trois jours une
chose tellement provocante quand se
souvient pas des choses propres comptes
qu'il a dit et pour qui rien donc ça
c'était un phénomène trop plein
maintenant on se rend compte qu'il ya
des choses dans la vie qui sont beaucoup
plus importantes que la trempe isation
dans ses discours de campagne on
retrouve en bon français beaucoup de
références aux vaucrises malakand celle
que chuck courant de pensée identifier
comme venant des états unis même si en
réalité c'est un peu plus compliqué que
ça qu'ils sont accusés par leurs
détracteurs plutôt à droite pour
schématiser de ronger un peu l'unité
nationale et par leur défenseur plutôt à
gauche je schématise toujours de lever
au contraire des tabous comment
trouvez-vous que la société française
avance sur ces questions ou n'avance pas
d'ailleurs enfin je pense que la laïcité
c'est un système qui pour la france a
très bien fonctionné pendant des
décennies et que cette idée de regarder
tous les citoyens sans voir les
distinctions entre ses citoyens c'est
quelque chose auquel on doit
réveil si on peut atteindre ça c'est
merveilleux évidemment dans la réalité
il y a eu beaucoup de problèmes dans ce
système et notamment avec le grande
influence de l'afrique du nord
d'immigrés musulmans avec le terrorisme
qui a beaucoup frappé la france plus que
d'autres pays européens et qui a créé
des fractures donc l'idée de laïcité je
pense a été en quelque sorte blessé par
ça mais le modèle français reste je
pense un modèle admirable c'est celle
atteindre qui est qui est difficile
toutes nos sociétés même la prochaine
des états unis qui est tout à fait
différente c'est pas que les problèmes
raciaux
se sont résolus il a été critiqué ce
modèle français notamment dans les
colonnes de votre journal
le new york times on avait l'impression
pendant plusieurs mois années de deux
pays de société qui ne se comprenait
plus de part et d'autre de l'atlantique
est ce que peut-être la présidence bill
donne à inverser un peu l'air un peu les
choses je pense que c'est ouais je pense
que plus que ça c'est surtout même il ya
quelques mois les relations entre les
etats-unis et la france n'était pas au
sommet avec la sphère des sous-marins et
tout ça mais je pense que encore une
fois cette cette guerre trois millions
de réfugiés on sait pas combien de
dizaines de milliers de gens blessés ou
tués on connaît ça quand même par
rapport à ça l'unité transatlantique
devient absolument critique très très
important pour nos valeurs pour nos
cultures qui en dépit des différences
quand incident sur beaucoup de questions
sur l'importance de l'état doit sur
l'importance de pouvoir exprimer ses
opinions sur la liberté sur des systèmes
ouverts pas fermé
et donc je pense que on a en a vu le
transatlantique mais qui s'est renforcée
beaucoup ce dernier mois joe biden en
deux mots sera en europe jeudi pour le
sommet de l'otan c'est peut-être son
déplacement le plus fort le plus
important alors je le disais c'est
peut-être mon
patriotisme enfin bon ma vision
française mais c'est un déplacement
symboliquement extraordinairement
important c'est très important il a
passé un moment difficile avec eux la
sortie abrupte et tumultueuse de
l'afghanistan je pense que depuis lors
et surtout depuis
ce qui s'est passé là avec la russie et
s'est montré assez fort et très porté
sur l'unité justement transatlantique
donc la décision de venir c'est encore
un signal pour dire on est tous ensemble
en ce moment contre cette russie du
président poutine il sera en pologne
vendredi d'ailleurs pas très loin de la
frontière ukrainienne merci beaucoup
rogers co end est revenu ce matin
d'emparé direct on retrouve bien sûr on
vous lit dans le new york times depuis
paris où vous continuez à suivre
notamment la campagne pour la
présidentielle bonne journée merci
beaucoup plus on se retrouve juste après
la pause avec damien hockey